what's up kids your thick ass friend
here
besha before we jump this podcast well
lacey and malik b
fighter in the kids few housekeeping
notes for you guys
uh thickies i will be in tampa florida
february 26-27
those shows almost sold out two shows
friday two shows saturday
february 26th 27th tampa improv and then
just added
cleveland one of my favorite places in
the world my favorite place to do comedy
cleveland ohio march 11th through the
13th z and that
is hilarities all right cleveland ohio
march 11th through the 13th
get your tickets now f-a-t-k-z dot-com
cleveland ohio you're on the clock
tampa see you soon this podcast is
brought to you by the one the
only on it on it.com fighter 10 off the
entire goddamn site
your friend here is thick i'm thick i'm
starting my weight loss journey
and thank god i have the help of on it
because on it has the best products on
the planet to get me to where i need to
go
your boy needs to lose 30 pounds
straight up 30 pounds
and i'll be lean and mean and thanks to
on it they're helping me out
i got freaking protein powder i got
earth grown nutrients
i got uh keto products i got creatine
krill oil joint oil total gut health
your your gut health is so freakin
important to your weight loss journey
so i'm using on it products join the
journey with your thick friend here
i'm still gonna be thick just a little
less thick man i get healthy
go to audit.com fighter i get my
workouts from there they have streaming
fitness they have at home programs for
you on it six streaming fitness
on in 30 kettlebell morning mobility
moving groove on at 30. we got
kettlebells for you steel club maces
battle ropes we got it all
go to on it.com fighter join this
workout
uh weight loss journey with your thick
friend here on it.com
[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter and he rolling with the
kids
dude i've really missed weights i mean
don't get wrong you hooked me up with
that that kettlebell it's one cap
very appreciative of of it but like and
i gave you the cross ropes
and the cross ropes shout out to
crossroads because those things are
[ __ ]
great
but anyways yeah crossroads gangster
kettlebell gangster but damn
i mean i need more man i missed like
like the dumbbells and like
yeah like the barbell like i don't know
man hey appreciate it
hey you you invited him over yeah tell
him what happened
uh he he he's he's got good form he can
work out
[ __ ] i mean what do you mean good legs
he's got good form he's like he knows
what he's doing he doesn't look awkward
working out
i thought he would well that one video
he sent us what are you like
uh squatting like oh the squatting yeah
i didn't see him squash
that's a nightmare that was probably
different that was last year
right late last year when y'all kept
picking on me by my legs the joke
stopped now because i have no
they're still there just give me a break
no we give you a break okay
either way we just backed up okay we'll
beat that as it may
uh i've been working out on the low
build the gym uh shout out to brendan
shop for the checks
and uh i just invest my money wisely
and built the whole gym you know ella is
closed so i invited my man over i'm like
bro
he's like the kettlebell workout there's
only so much you can do with the
kettlebell kettlebells let's be honest
you have a kettlebell yeah
you should have one you did now we have
pull-ups in our workout
i want to talk about this um home's
tough when you're a big boy
bruh we had to ban like no
[ __ ] that band i don't need that band
that band was listen
you put the band on your knee yeah bro
meanwhile that's embarrassing
i didn't know i didn't believe until i
saw that gut when he was trying to pull
it i was like okay my man he's
struggling because he was pulling up
there's a lot of weight to pull up his
shirt his shirt lifted up and i saw that
big keg
underneath i was like hey huh you feel
like i got a kick get the [ __ ]
out of here do you see me i'm not that
big
i mean i was like i'm just saying
man not a cat it ain't a six-pack and a
six-pack if you had a sex
tape you wouldn't be proud of you i say
i got a 24-pack
there's nobody okay uh yeah turtle shell
i got started we both got turtle shells
we got turtle shells but but you know
what like it's not like
it's not that you know you're gonna be
hard for us to lose our turtle shell no
so like don't say i got a kick you
didn't even want to do sit-ups you said
kiss my ass
is that what you said yeah i was done
yeah he's over it yeah but
you want to lose that keg so therefore
it's sit-ups it's a workout
is gonna help me lose all my diet yeah
i miss weights too so i'm going to build
one i think they're called shed gyms
what's going to get a dope shed yep and
i'm going to set up you know my
basketball court
yeah half the court i'm going to turn to
the shed gym what about the gym at my
crib i shared james
shed jim it's like this new craze right
now see that one on the way fair one
it's gonna look like don't bring up the
shed you see the far left one on way for
your chin yeah wait
that that's what i'm gonna do that's
hard i know i'm gonna do i know i'm
gonna do i'm build a gym out of a shed
oh dude yeah i look hard i'm telling you
that's what i'm gonna do
so i have so what are you gonna get in
there because i don't i don't like
driving the gym anymore it takes away
from my kids and stuff
so as soon as they go to school i'm just
having the gym upstairs i'm gonna have a
trainer come over i'm gonna do that now
yeah i mean
while riding my bike yeah but i can't
just ride my bike see i live in i live
in an apartment and i
i don't like i guess what where i
struggle is you live an apartment i
thought it was a house no
not a house oh wait yeah it's an
apartment uh but uh
wha what i don't like is like having my
my gym at my apartment what is my home
to be my home oh i feel you you know
what i mean like i don't i don't want
you
a little different yeah i don't want to
go anywhere yeah i don't want to have to
but
you're sitting i don't have to talk to
your situation where you put it on your
court
you got a [ __ ] castle yeah i
don't have a castle i have an apartment
you know what i'm saying i see right
i guess it's just i didn't like working
out when i when i lived in apartments in
like uh
town houses i didn't like walking to the
i didn't like the gym in the apartment
back when you were sleeping on that uh
blow-up mattress yeah it does
shot arch stuff it was archstone
apartments
but that i would do that in a heartbeat
yeah that's my plan
that's your plan that's my pleasure bro
mike dolce
who's that mike dolce he's a famous uh
dietician guy
he's okay with a lot of ufc fighters him
and i used to train together
uh-huh you know my thing i need someone
to hold me accountable
you know what i'm saying accountability
but look but look look how big he used
to be
go up jen see the far right look at that
oh that's him right there that's him
bro he worked his ass off yes he worked
his ass off
and he and he doesn't believe in like he
doesn't believe in like
killing yourself he doesn't believe in
like uh uh
starving yourself you don't believe in
like keto he didn't believe in uh
carnivore diet
so what does he do with good foods i got
called him today to lock it in
and then you know cause i've never been
bigger man
i'm 272 right now dude i'm big as [ __ ]
too
dude we're being honest about our weight
right now yeah i'm probably up there
like 255 i want to say
yeah that's the biggest i've ever been
yeah you're probably hearing that
you know you kiss my ass what are you
talking about
you got a scale jim you can get a scale
you can bring one in next time
we need to bring one you're 260. stop
and it's
it's
okay what are you are you six no i'm not
six
i wish i was two sixteen it's not a big
deal i'm not 260. i'm five eleven
you're you're high fifty five add three
four pounds
you're right you're fee that's me in the
middle you're two fifty eight
two fifty eight all right i'm too big
yeah yeah does it suck what yeah i'm
about to get tattooed 272 on my hand so
every time i reach for a [ __ ] cookie
or something
for reals i know i just i have to go
extreme
yeah i have to go extreme see i just had
that beast of a chocolate chip cookie
from crosstalk that's
the best cookie in l.a damn it i should
have done that i should have
i didn't need that it's all about diet
it's all about that that's what you
learn it's all in like trainings like
timber but you know what's weird about
you is like you're a picky [ __ ] eater
but you don't eat necessarily eat like
extremely healthy he's also an ectomorph
like he ain't what does that mean
about this no he can do anything to stay
thin like same as calling
yeah so like like nothing you don't work
out you just get skinny
i get skinny yeah you're an ectomorph
nothing nothing
i don't know what that means nothing is
worse than when a a skinny guy is giving
you tips about your diet
oh word [ __ ] you don't
come from the bible if you don't if you
don't come from [ __ ] if you don't
have 258
272. yeah if you don't know genetics get
out of here
can you help me out it's like a white
guy telling me about racism
just dropping knowledge hey bro you need
to be kind to these black women
it's systematic racism you're like bro
you're a
rich white guy yeah gary you're no
different
gary owens like yo you protect that
black woman i'll take that black woman
no but like like for real like it is
weird like hearing a skinnier dude like
because i'm going to talk to you about
get on my face bro you know get on my
face
you guys don't know the same struggle no
yeah they don't know the struggle like
to feel this weight do you know what the
[ __ ] it feels like
you're saying a guy in a person's
professional skinny guy trainer who's
like
get that [ __ ] out of my mind get out of
my face get out of my face
it's like someone who can't sing tell me
how to sing yeah
why it's just like someone that's not a
comedian telling you how to [ __ ] do
your jokes which happens all the time
what's happening are you not even better
it's like a real shitty comedian
telling the headliner how to do jokes
exactly you're like you shouldn't say it
like
you're on this level you're not even on
this little you never touched this level
yeah but
i'm saying if the guy is like studying
his master's studies
this amount of weight no i don't you
know what it's like but you know what
it's like to flip this body every time
people go should we
do a backflip do it backwards yes my
hands come off wheezing bro i come off
wheezing every time
that's how you know he's doing the
backflip from the back
yeah but i get it but again it's all
about don't want you telling me about no
diet yeah
matter of fact shut up dude yeah you're
not about this life what are you talking
about
you and justin both sticks
we can tell you how to gain weight no no
no no no i already know how to get out
of the gateway yes you eat four times a
day
right now this is a this is why i come
into play so this is what my dad taught
me
right so you drink first thing we wake
up you drink a gallon
that's what i'm talking about i don't
care right here
what do you think he's
[Music]
out yup right go work her out when you
finish get from the workout you eat your
breakfast that she's gonna eat before
the workout
and your uh post-workout meal together
yeah right because
it's easier on your body exactly then
you chill out then you go work out again
because i'm you know ectomorphic okay
too easy for that you are
yeah you don't have two workouts today
i'll knock it out no you knock it off
i'm not gonna work out well either way
then you eat your
lunch and your dinner combined after
yeah after the workout so what you're
going to eat before
the workout and your dinner you eat at
the same time you eating twice a day but
you're doing it
just after your workout yeah yeah and
you it's four meals combined
into two easy on your digestive system
and you gain weight faster
oh this is to gain weight yeah we're
trying to lose weight
oh i guess i i knew what you were
talking about i was like i was like he's
trying to gain weight yeah i'm trying to
gain weight all right
all right you're trying to lose either
way he'll tell you the same thing drink
a lot of water you know water may help
you lose weight did you know that it's
probably
very aware of all this okay is it
probably is it probably quicker for us
to lose weight
than for him to gain weight yes yeah
it's harder to put muscle and then lose
weight
putting them real i put muscle on fast
though really oh yeah
you look exactly the same now if i take
my shirt off you don't see the
difference
i'm just saying you look the same i'm uh
hell
i've never known you i started the other
day i started this podcast i was 158
what do you know i'm 172. you look
exactly you're [ __ ] alive are you
serious i'm dead
i'm 172.
let's take a little bit of a break
because i'm here to tell you about
helix sleep mattresses listen there's
nobody on the planet like you
so why would you just assume the
mattress you sleep on is built for you
they're not they're built for every joe
schmoe out there
but thanks to helix sleep they have a
little quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete then it matches you
and your thick ass body type with the
exact mattress built for you it's the
perfect mattress just for you what are
you side sleeper
hot sleeper plush firm bed whatever you
want helix gotcha
covered there's no more confusion no
more compromise on the average mattress
helix sleep was even awarded number one
best overall mattress pick of 2019 and
2020
by gq and wired magazine i get them at
my crib i can't get rid of my friends
and family because everybody wants to
stay over because they're the perfect
mattress that's built just for them and
you can join the club of these perfect
mattresses by going to helixsleep.com
take their two minute sleep quiz
they will match you with your customized
mattress that will give you the best
night of your sleep
forever they have a 10 year warranty you
get to try it out for 100 nights risk
free they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but you're well so
don't worry about that
helix is offering you guys up to 200 off
all mattress orders and free pillows
for you guys at helixleep.com fighter
that's fighter for up helixsleep.com 200
off today's episode is brought to you by
the kratom experts at super speciosa
all right if you've ever heard of kratom
you've heard me rant and rave about
kratom i don't do a podcast
i don't do stand-up i don't do anything
workouts without kratom i swear
by it i love it alright if you don't
know what it is
you got to make sure you get the real
deal holyfield kratom
you can't just get it from your mom and
pop shop don't get off venice boardwalk
get it from a trusted brand like super
speciosa
that's who i trust that's why they're on
this podcast because i get a lot of
requests about what kratom i use i use
superspeciosa that's what i use because
i can trust them
if you don't know what it is you've
never heard of kratom it's a herbal
supplement kinda like cbd but instead
it's come from the cannabis plant
some close to a coffee tree people use
kratom every day like your boy
like chin uh i use it for energy and
mental clarity
but you can use it for a freaking relief
of occasional pain
energy support pre-workout man's stress
whatever you're looking for
kratom will get it done for you all
right and
and super speciosa they keep their
kratom the way nature intended it all
right
it's pure you can trust them all right
um
they're gonna give you guys 20 off so if
you're looking for a cheap way to try
kratom you're looking for a trustworthy
brand super speciosa is that brand
that's what i use every freaking day
so if you want to try it out they're
going to give you guys 20 off go to
getsuperleaf.com
fighter that's get super leaf
dot com slash fighter enter promo code
fighter for 20
off that's getsuperleaf.com fighter
that's getsuperleaf.com promo code
fighter
i started this podcast i was 158 what do
you know i'm 172. you look exactly you
[ __ ] lie
are you serious i'm dead i'm serious i'm
172. that's fine
bro yes bro when is the last time you've
been in the ones
the ones like 100s oh eighth grade
freshman you know what junior
junior of high school i was one you know
what
i'm sick of your skinny [ __ ] knowledge
dude
i'm not trying to oh
this goes for anyone who's going to
email us
dude unless you're 200 plus
it's been a minute since i've been in
the one i thought you thought about
jordan
does your girl say anything ever about
your weight
sure yeah she'll look at my gut
sometimes be like hey
yeah she'll rub it like jamie foxx what
you doing
like the apollo stuff my girls should be
like i mean you're definitely bigger
than when we met i'm like yeah yeah
she's
that's not helping yeah i need you to
fat shaming [ __ ] yeah
i need you to make fun of me like this
this being cool
it's not working yes i think i look cool
tell me to put the [ __ ] chips down
like why are you ordering a [ __ ]
burrito i've never seen a girl i know if
she exists but the thing is with my girl
her genetics are stupid her and her mom
you've seen my girl and her mom
genetics are stupid so no matter what
she does she has a flat stomach
so we'll be watching you know we're on a
season one of true detective
watching for a second oh my god that's a
beautiful show one of the best shows
ever yeah
so boo will be watching that and she's
like i feel like a snacky so she'll get
out those flaming hot cheetos
or should you get out the uh what is it
the the spicy uh doritos
and the show order those ones that we'll
get on the road the tapatio ones
yeah oh i haven't had that oh they're
fantastic they are don't even start no
don't don't don't okay so she get those
and then she knows i love boba so she'll
order boba
but she can do it she can do that yeah
and she stays skinny
all that good i can't do that that's the
thing i got my ass jiggling the next day
oh that's true i think that's i think
that's our thing is that the people we
surrounded with they could eat that way
we can i'm like yeah let's go get
burritos i'm gonna tattoo 272 on my
[ __ ]
that's not true jay is kind of he's big
and swole and he's healthy with me
and uh stevie we all all this uh really
eats what we he does yeah bro he will
tell
bruh watch it here he's gonna text us
and be like jay's a big dude
but i mean he's not fat like me but
jay's a big he's a big dude slow pajama
he's like you and i had a kid like he's
kind of like yeah
yeah but he act like he his last picture
was him and jelly roll that was a while
ago look at that my man got his oars
i mean that's that's not a good
comparison because jelly roll
we can't tell what jake loves jelly roll
bring j
uh that one no no the one of us in utah
springs no wait wait wait wait the one
with the shirt look at him yeah that one
yo dallas right there
look at that jay not you're not oh [ __ ]
i see that punch jay
but he's not my point is he's not look
like look at you and justin and steve
you guys are thin
people dude yeah jason little look at
klopp just freaking pop is big
clown is enormous i text clop how much i
weigh it's too big
just too worried that's just funny you
see yeah but too big look at j i mean
yeah jay's like
but what my point is jay's not like a uh
he's not like a guy
and also he's not yeah like arms on him
he's not necessarily built like you and
i either
he's just a bigger dude yeah like he
like he don't have like the
he don't gotta he don't have a turtle
[ __ ] what happened to you y'all
competition 90 day though
get off of us [ __ ] that conversation
[ __ ] bro we ain't competing
i haven't competed you know three times
y'all brought up like y'all was gonna
lose weight is this the final straw
right here you had to drink you hot
you don't think i want to walk on the
ice like you're skinny
yeah we have pizza parties on this show
yeah we had like uh what else we have
chicken chicken salad doughnuts i mean
god damn
y'all don't sit back and look like hold
on maybe we're doing too much you know
y'all
who started this competition nobody put
a gun to your head and say yo 90 day the
other way let's do it y'all did your own
little dap
all that you're still talking [ __ ] man
no chill bruh no i'm i'm 98 the other
way for sure you see i took my shirt
off you saw them you look exactly okay
be that out of your work you look at
exactly
should we take before pictures do you
think that will help y'all
i did it last night i did it last night
rock [ __ ] i've been talking to mike
dolce years i was like yo
chubby need your help he said say less
how much away i told him
okay we got work to do we got work to do
so i'll get shredded in three months
no no i said i like your confidence yeah
that ain't happening
you told him that three months if he's
working with you you
give give a man a chance yeah i know
he's also also he knows he comes from
the big world
it'd be different if he said i'd be like
kiss my ass you liar listen
that's a great idea you all should both
take the before
i gotta put it on for i already got mine
you gotta put on fighting the kid though
y'all have to look at that only after i
get shredded
wait i don't want to just post it right
now
but you know no one does that bro
i was embarrassing freaking re-posting
yeah you uh filming me doing the pull-up
oh yeah i saw that guy you got a body
like booker off of good times i saw that
it was like oh
yo i'm trying to tell you it's right
here a little it's not that we gotta hit
rock bottom dude
yeah i'm on rock bottom i'm sad about it
man we yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna do something dude i'm telling
you i
gotta go really extreme i'm never gonna
i gotta get in shape for my kids man bro
the fact that i can't even
[ __ ] you yeah that's a 1977 buffalo bus
that's from the 70s it came
from the seven well it came on tv
i'm just saying it was one professor
wrapping
you don't be a bad example yeah you
don't do you care about having like
absolutely okay cause you could lose
weight listen
i don't need i don't need a [ __ ]
six-pack okay i've been down to
you i've been down to 225 when i was
doing this uh jiu-jitsu competition i
got to 224
and i still don't have abs some people
just start like my stomach was kind of
flat and you could see like my uh
the v and it was probably the thinnest
i've been but i've
it's just not my body type's just not
shredded there's one problem
i'm willing to do
what was that uh i'm talking hydroxycut
hey i'm talking
remember that one i'm talking whatever
it takes up
whatever i'm ready to go dark world with
it no don't do that i'm ready to go will
smith and ali
with it what did he do
what did he do i mean everything for
real raleigh
i'm ready to go michael b jordan creed
with it come on
okay i wanted to go force gump with it
okay
but brendan there's one picture of you
at a weigh-in that's gonna be me
typing british shop weigh-in or whatever
google picture
i know you look straight at it yeah
never been shredding well you had a bald
head
you had a ball headed a little bit
wait where's my ball head when he's ball
headed these are all like uh shaved head
never mind you probably thought when i
was fighting orlovsky but that see
that's pretty i'm
see
right there right around 240. it's a
little v
i love how you try to like get some abs
and it's like
is that an echo what yeah i'm sponsored
by echo
oh are you looking at his underwear i
don't even see that echo
yeah his underwear you see it oh okay
yeah and it says it on the left
it might those shorts are echo see the
the oh on the side oh
here's the thing about that though is uh
i love your lips
here's the thing about that i uh think
about it man i was running
eight miles a day three times a day like
that like i'm not gonna get professional
athlete body yeah you know it's just
that's just like my my entire
my my financial means was based off my
athletic performance so yeah so you had
to be
life it's not life now yeah it's just
not i can go on stage at 400 pounds
it don't matter that's literally how it
was for me i can do this podcast on 300
it don't matter
that's the problem but accountability
that's the word of the day today so
we're going to 272 on your hand
no i'm not holding him accountability
you know i'm not i'm not doing that
no i hope you get right but if you don't
i still love you yeah exactly
yeah it's just tough when you like i
remember my homie was trying to help me
uh get him to quit smoking he said hi my
cigarettes i said i got you
yeah found him did you john he found him
you're not a problem
not a good hider that's what i'm saying
i'm not i'm not working this i'm like oh
you're still gonna [ __ ] do it
but the good thing is my girl's getting
my girls down like seven pounds her body
is ridiculous right right she's working
out but she's working out a lot
she got the sled damn i just bought one
yeah i want a sled man there's something
yeah i just don't want i just don't want
it all in my apartment
i guess it's all like i'm gonna build
that gym it's gonna take a while though
but
i'll just get on my diet until the gym
is built nah i don't want it wait
where's it at
over there in the east hollywood yeah
you don't want to don't go to that area
well don't say that it's a game it's a
gate you saw that it's
a gate but still you don't know
weren't you on tlc for that 300 pounds
are you eating right now chin what
sardines i don't know why i was freaking
starving but hummus yeah
i have a video of my
old one though get that money chance get
there have you ever been big
uh yeah i like go up and down and wait a
lot like i put on 20 pounds pretty
easily
yeah and that's big for how small you
are yeah because i'm like five one
putting on 20 pounds is a lot
yeah oh
[ __ ] mm-hmm what's the other guy look
like my friend dave and that's james
god let's see look how big it was oh
there you go
yeah i love that fat dude look at this
right here
yes yeah
go back to the spikes jen i like that
look at that right there yeah it goes
back to this place
look at this guy okay
you had no confidence in yourself huh i
mean i didn't really care too much about
weight and then
but then eventually i was like i wanted
to get in shape and then once i decided
i just did it that's so crazy it's
discipline
yeah but you don't go you don't go to
the gym
no this is all diet literally this is
just diet look at the veggies coming out
they say they say diets the the big one
mm-hmm and then why did you see the
veins popping out look at that right
there dude that was my most ripped
damn you were shredded yeah yeah you
didn't go to the gym then
no i did just dumbbells at home push-ups
damn look at you
how much did you weigh there 180 70
probably jesus
christ and i actually had i never i'm
like you were i never i thought it was
impossible for me to have abs
yeah but then once i started getting
like leaner leaner leaner that's right
you've seen them
and then you're like oh [ __ ] i want to
do more tomorrow i know yeah that's
crazy
a meal with b.j penn
spotlight cause donnie what did you
weigh in that picture we just looked up
that's probably 236 there 236 is that
what you want to get to
uh i'd like to 240. i'd like 240. yeah
240 is realistic for me
i'd like to lose 30. 240 i feel like i'm
still kind of big yeah
yeah yeah your height you need to be
around 215 to
really 215. 220.
220. let's go 220 for you right i can't
let's say wait let's say
let's say you weigh 225 i mean 255.
i think higher let's say you need to
lose
uh i'd say 30 pounds 30 pounds
you could eat so do i we both lose 30
pounds 30 pounds is solid
okay now 10 pounds a month everyone's
like is that is that what you're
supposed to do
if you're losing weight like in a yeah
how am i supposed to lose it you look so
confused right now that's good
come to the skinny don't come to hell no
no i don't want to hear you
i don't want to hear about your homies
let me see what i give me and then i'll
send your way
okay baby won't you come my way
close your eyes when you say it i don't
know but yeah
have you put weight on chin i'm
definitely but then also i'm like look
you still look good
i'm skinny fat now though are you really
the only thing i would give advice about
toe jam in earl is if you lose weight
you have to maintain your like your
muscle mass because it goes away and
then that's why you get more you get
more motivated because you're losing
more weight but you're losing muscle too
i'll take it but your metabo your
metabolism is great
yeah i have a high metabolism i don't go
crazy with food that's why yeah only
korean barbecue
how much you weigh right now 185 maybe
wow
i've never seen i've never seen chin
chin
sheen i've never seen chen uh eat a
piece of bread or anything oh yeah nice
yeah
you know who else does [ __ ] with any
bread or carbs is andrew schultz
wow like he likes this dog he's like i
don't [ __ ] with any carbs man
he was just on like bread i like bread
bro
yeah when we had that barbecue bruh he
got that white bread
oh he talked about it he took that white
bread and [ __ ] just
no more man piled [ __ ] up on there 272.
but i you know i got it because i have
to eat the barbecue
in kc when i'm there february 25th to
27th
uh bro everybody's been dropping
references or
recommendations some great spots out
there i think joe's is a famous one
they named joe's the gas station mm-hmm
oh it's a gas station
pretty sure it's well it's like next to
the gas station
gas station yeah joe's is really really
good ten thousand reviews five out of
five stars basically literally and
people keep mentioning that q39
i've been there you've been there i've
been to all these videos what do you
think
they're all really really good they're
all fantastic
all right kansas city now now but not
better than truth
no that's just spot in houston yeah no
truth the best barbecue ever had
better than pecan lodge all of them and
we love pecan lodge
is better juice best barbecue in the
world you don't like
juice and then brothers barbecue in
denver but
what you get when we eat barbecue you
you don't
count bro you get [ __ ] chicken
i'm just saying you get chicken okay
where you going
right have you ever had you see that
when you see that bro and they squeeze
it and you see the juice
i put in my [ __ ] mouth yeah put that
in my [ __ ] mouth i put that on my
butt
hey i uh that's the other thing
no more red meat you're not doing red
meat thank you
i'm not eating red meat because
obviously it's not mixing well with my
body
with the diet yeah you can eat whatever
the [ __ ] you want you just eat chicken
yeah but i can't read meat because i did
the carnivore where i was just eating
red meat i just
kept waiting the red meat sticks to my
that's what i'm saying
it's probably different for everybody
because rogan did it he did the the
carnival carnivore diet what broken's on
a lot of [ __ ] dude
[Laughter]
don't lose weight
[Laughter]
i'm not good he sounded like a little
kid
i want to lose weight no brendan sounds
like every girl
who buys like a booty program on
instagram from a girl who bought her
butt
yup oh that was happening yeah a lot of
those girls not all of them but a lot of
instagram girls who
have fitness programs get their bodies
done and then try to get there
there's gotta be at least one that's got
a real booty
everyone thinks it's fake and i'm like
that girl though we talked about summer
rae she has a real loss
she does yeah it's fantastic
her yes she's 24 25 yeah oh was that who
we were battling with
megan foxx
that's a professional wrestler
but yeah this girl she comes from
yeah both of her parents are
bodybuilders
so okay so she was probably good yeah
she woke up i love her
me i also love her good god
now hold on cat when i hear when i see
their belly button like
that a lot of people say like if you
don't have a belly button
you it's obviously you have some work
done so what do you mean if you don't
like
you know if you're like if it's flat or
like if you don't see her belly button
they said
she had you know well and seen you no
that's real
that's real that's real it's so like
pointy god
when you say it's a lot of thought like
my girls
like if you feel their ass you guys
won't yeah
it's like it's like all it's like all
muscle yeah oh god it's like
a pure muscle those things
they're not they're not muscular it's
fat it's like a hard fat
okay a heart fat what's hard about it is
ridiculous
oh so she legit works out yeah yeah see
she been in her on her dead
rdl she's been a little bit in her
backyard so yeah i also need a
i need a trainer to come to crib if
you're a trainer in the valley hit me up
i got you
not you dude okay a legit trainer come
to craig
she's so fine get her out of here hey my
boy lives in the valley
long hair don't care the oh the the
the gorgeous man with that long hair and
he lives in the valley he lives he's not
too far from he's a trainer
and he's a dietitian mm-hmm okay
he does not look too far from you got
good hair as well bernie i know you like
that i love his hair yeah i know
could you do that here um i'd do that
yeah you look like you're throwing my
[ __ ] out
[ __ ] it do it i'm doing it right if
you're going to do yeah if you're going
to do this
wait oh yeah we got to get the groin put
on a cecil hotel podcast
process of it yeah you should connect me
to your boy
yeah he lives super close really yeah
all right
with mark harley hella mark harley yeah
he looks super close to you
uh what are you talking about haircuts
yeah i got done up
mm-hmm you did oh you didn't yeah all
right well you're all in the tail y'all
couldn't say that no it looked like a
little bit
like wesley slips in blade what what's
why this right here is too high i don't
like the size because i like it
but it isn't really blending first of
all i don't i don't get my hair done
in a way for you to [ __ ] like you
know i get it done [ __ ] improvement
yeah
i'm looking for this it's not great it's
not blended yeah that's what i'm saying
what are you talking about
bro i'm here to help you as a friend
it's not blending it
and you should you pay 60 you pay 60 huh
and i'll still pay 60
for that i like it if you like i look
good that's all that matters i like it i
love it yeah does your girl like it
yep you're good then all right then i'm
just saying it's not a 60 dollar haircut
brenden 60's high man for that mexican
my mexicans up the street
i already went to that guy wow what the
[ __ ] is going on
you better make sure that's what you
want because that's what you get yeah he
told me he said brendan sent you i was
like brandon
napkins can't say
that's what's up though congrats are you
still doing the braids oh i'm still
doing it bro losing because i
cuz i asked the dude i said what do i
like how do i need like how should i
cause a black barber right uh i don't
know what he is
not black he's i don't know i don't know
he's got like a
maybe an arabic last name you need a
black guy if you're gonna ask a black
egg question yeah
yeah hey what should i do to write
braids i'm not asking armenian about
braids
i'm not asking a skinny guy about weight
loss exactly you're asking a
armenian about braiding your hair he's
like i would i would grow it out
wait is that you're like all right is
that your armenian now man
i regrew it out
you gotta have some black guy about
black hair man hey when you get the
braids and you with your weight loss
you're gonna be looking like a real
legit
i'm trying to look like deontay wilder
hell yeah okay that's nice
what does he look like he looks great he
does go to his instagram let's see
yeah let's go let's just see like a
recent pick he has some style too man i
know
because you know his wife is a stylist
right or something like that oh is she
really she comes from that world i can't
see his hair there
[ __ ] oh so he's dead what was that he
did this now
oh should i do that nah you don't look
like cris
that would look dope too on you man yeah
can you grow a beard
no dude i don't know how to [ __ ] grow
a beard yeah i just started
looking sad as [ __ ] that's the sexy pick
you got the lemonized
ain't sexy yeah he's trying he's trying
to look light skinned in that photo
anyways in gaza um i believe in glasgow
that means shout out to jay for liking
it jay sharp liked it yeah
of course hey go let me see his let me
see his truck
is that top uh yeah oh that's a
fantastic
[ __ ] those
that's a bummer that's a [ __ ] um no
yeah i
okay a beard yeah me neither it's tough
dude another thing we got to work on i
used to do
i used to do clean shaving for years
yeah
and then not not until i was like 30 31
is when i started trying to grow a beard
and it just it stays like this you got
you gotta have those products
like so i gotta get a product yeah from
yeah like to help your
beer grow it's kind of like your hair is
it like what uh
torrey lanes did with his hair oh no
that he brought that tiger now you don't
want that tiger that's an implant he
does a hair
hair implant now you don't want that no
you know you can't do that for a beard
hell yeah it's fake boy
floyd did it no bro they got a whole
uh wig for beards yeah take it easy you
don't want that you don't want that one
[Laughter]
some white chick [ __ ] i know damn all
right well i need to get product damn
my boy mano did it so so i said so i got
a defender right for my dad wagon
the official thick boy uh ride and so
it came like a blue they have like these
standard colors so it came blue with
off-road package
and so i hit my boy up at rdb la mano i
was like yo
i want it vintage like the the old
school
defenders so i sent a picture of that i
said this what i want to do to that
and that's what we did damn it's hard
bruh that's right
hey do you have the the rims uh i have
i have the yeah the my rims are bronze
on that car yeah you
you okay but that's where the
inspiration came from
white white roof uh like british green
paint because the british car you were
talking you talking about jeep rims what
are good jeep rims
there's a ton jeep because they've been
around so long there's so many options
for jeep yeah
we did a two inch lift on that two inch
lift mud flaps off-road package it's
pretty filthy
oh yeah i'm obsessed with that go crazy
i know
i'm uh getting the cleanest [ __ ] i'm
getting a range rover uh in the next two
months
oh which one
i wanted the bmw m4 i was talking to jay
i was like and i was talking to my girl
she was like yo range rover is kind of
like your style i was like all right bet
someone get the black on black met black
though and uh
are you gonna lease it what are you
gonna do yeah use button i'm gonna no
i'm gonna buy it i'm not gonna get
leased
to ask my pops i was like let me lease
it he was like nah because you want to
lease it because then
you pay all that money you get a new car
and you're just wasting money
uh love your dad he's wrong he's wrong
yeah he's wrong
hey man it's time to talk about the only
genes i wear i'm talking about
rav town jeans man roughtown created the
holy grail of jeans anybody who works
out or exercises
you know how it is if you're a thick boy
out there and you're looking for
thick jeans to help you last all right
i'm talking about they can last for 50
years
it's impossible to squeeze into some
sandpaper denim from china
or go a size up in the way so it looks
freaking droopy so your booty's all
sagging we don't want that want you to
look good rev town was created by a
couple guys
who started under armour so now they
know a thing of two about
world-class performance workout clothes
and leggings and other gear
guess what they partnered up with this
old school denim designer milan
italy ever heard of it to create jeans
that look good and also
fit good for your thick ass no wonder
the fast grown
growing denim brand on the planet for
men and women
they start at 79 bucks a pair they are
less than half the price from those
so-called
designer jeans we've been jamming our
stuff into for years
and they're freaking amazing pick up a
pair of revtown.com
fighter pick up a pair at revtown.com
fighter they've got something special
just for you guys listening right now
you gotta check it out
head over to revtown.com fighter to
upgrade your denim game today
revtown.com fighter so uh
they're gonna be a work right because so
if that's your forever car
as so when you buy let's say you buy
that car brand new okay
especially in that land rover sport as
soon as you drive off the lot
in three years the value's half cut in
half
so you're stuck paying those high high
rates on that that car
pay it off it's all paid off or a lease
for you can ride
you can so if you buy the car you can't
write anything off if you lease it
for work let's say you toss on a rolly
boy logo what the [ __ ] can do with it
i'll probably
you can you can ride it off a leash can
write off a but if you buy it you can't
write it off
also get at least now at least yes at
least your payment
should be lowered depending how much you
put down and also in three years
you can buy it you have the option to
buy it and you have lower payments which
might be the way to go if you love it
you can buy it or you can trading just
get the new version
if you want if you're a guy who likes
new [ __ ] yeah i do you want a lease
i'm a lease again so what the hell my
pops just talking about i don't know
that it's like that's kind of an
old-school way of thinking there's
certain cars you wanna buy yeah
you cars you want to buy like cars that
hold their value like
a porsche or hold their value like a
[ __ ]
if it's a collector's eyes and porsche
you're going to buy it um
if if it's a car that you really want to
sports car you want to buy it because
the lease
they're going to be like 3 000 miles a
year we're going to be 3 000 miles in
like
three months probably if you're driving
to work correct so certain certain cars
you're going to buy certain cars you
want a lease
but like that i wouldn't i wouldn't buy
that those are dime a dozen so
you know but like g-wagons hold their
value really well so you want to buy
that
you know there's certain cars i thought
that was going to come on a lease
yeah jeeps yes because there's always
going to be another g on average
okay gotcha damn it's like a limited
edition collector's item or something
you know you're gonna want yeah then buy
it
okay oh [ __ ] that well let's get you out
of that center bro yeah i'm tired of
that
you were trying to get a car wash with
us and we were like yeah yeah i don't
like how
you know
god washes your car god
it's up to god to wash your car
if you have that center you let god
decide
and that thing's just god out here let
you know hey you need a car washer first
[ __ ] and all right decides
when you're crashing i love how it was
everyone was talking about everyone uh
here at the studios like oh we can do a
group call
there's a bunch of dope rides out there
i was like wait someone from the staff
was like hey
we're gonna pay someone to come watch
the cars mal goes hey can you wait till
monday
i went no we're not hold on no we're not
waiting
we're not gonna wait because again god's
gonna decide
when you get a car walk you drive that
sort of ride
gave me a sermon on a wednesday the lord
yeah once you get the new centers though
oh don't do that
no is that bad i gotta get out the
central man you gotta get out the
central guys
there's a bunch of dub crashing in the
lease and they're giving good leases
right now because you know we're
covered yeah and the prices are great i
just don't want the prices are great man
i don't like to get recognized because
y'all gotta recognize we got rusty
knives when we was gonna pick up uh
brendan's car
oh yeah imagine you see me like hey is
that rolly boy
oh in the center yeah tag still dirty
and that's why i drive us to work every
day
appreciate you you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah that jeep's dumb you like your
car cat
oh i love my car yeah you're talking
about getting up in the phantom
phantom with your only fans but that new
money
do you want a new car no uh no i'm not
somebody who really like buys a lot of
new stuff like that yeah you're not
materialistic she rocked the minivan for
a minute
oh yeah i used to drive my mom's minivan
yeah she wrote the thing was hot yeah i
think she was jealous
to eat in the back of that thing yeah
i've never seen it
yeah the macans are dope though oh those
are so fun to drive what year is yours
uh 2020. uh
no my uh parents went half on me uh for
it because i was gonna get the same
honda that i had before that
uh got wrecked in the car accident and
it's about half the price of the
porsche my parents said that they'll pay
the other half of my payments
if i'm if i want a porsche instead of a
honda so i was like [ __ ] yeah
and now dude do your parents realize how
much money you're making they don't need
to provide happiness
they do know that they don't care they
don't care but yeah now i
make all the papers that's cool though
oh that's dope look at you cat
i got a call late last night man from my
best friend she's asian as well
florida we brought her up on the podcast
she
someone was walking on the freewa way on
the 110 i guess they do
do that so they walked the car hit him
yeah and then he ricocheted and hit her
and her body flew
and she was like best friend i killed
somebody and i would can i say this on
fire well she already did the police
report and all that yeah so so she was
she was calling me and crying
and it was a report i was like nah
you're probably not the first one we
googled it
a lot of people these homeless people
walk on the freeway at night to commence
to commit commission yeah i didn't know
that and she associate but
yeah and then she just got that car damn
yeah that's why you have insurance
though
yeah she said the police report she was
like her insurance is good your best
friend killed a guy that's what i was
saying i was like yo but she was like
the pieces flew everywhere i was like
what a transition man we were talking
about cats upgrading
right your friend called you because she
got some new fans
oh my best friend called last time
damn valentine that was tough
yeah i can't wait for the 66 666 episode
hotel podcast that's a rough way to go
man
guys oh god but again i mean she's she's
dope that was her first time seeing the
dead body so i kind of coasted through
it and stuff so
what you're saying i was like [ __ ] it's
going to be it's going to be plenty of
more just
just that makes sense i know there's
gonna be plenty more play more what
hitting people in cars no i'm just
saying play more dead bodies
bro i don't know what the hell just tell
her brother not that
i don't even know why you told this
story oh well because it's dark
it was yesterday but i wanted to be an
older guy
[ __ ] i don't know where we transitioned
yeah yeah i was like
shouldn't you ever kill the guy i
believe everyone was reacting he was
like yeah they do he
knew about the uh people coming soon oh
you knew about that
no i didn't actually oh no i can imagine
though yeah first time i've ever heard
it are y'all saying well
i remember years ago there's there's
that highway that um
what is it i forget what highway it is
but there's those bridges over it
this dude was threatening to jump so
they stopped traffic because he wasn't
jumping on kevin traffic
we were stuck there for like two hours
some old lady people out here
yeah people have their cars changed he's
in downtown right like
it's like when you're like you passed
grinshall and going to the airport so
it's like when you uh if you want to go
to elon musk's uh the tesla
what's the highway out there you get off
crenshaw and the airport's right there
105.05
105. what what 105.105. i was on the
105.
and where the traffic was stopped for
hours and people were out of their cars
chilling talking blah blah
some old lady was like just [ __ ] do
it already
and he did it like certainly he didn't
do it oh cops got to him
well you know someone jumped off the
wall he was like 75 was like just
[ __ ] do it already
you ruined everybody's lifeline goddamn
[ __ ]
ruining everybody's life
[Laughter]
someone jumped off the 105. they do it
all the time oh yeah
that was a couple of years ago damn yeah
it got dark so
yeah so yeah yeah yeah don't do that
anyways cat yeah
okay we're talking about on your only
fans is it just pictures or do you have
to
does stevie help you edit [ __ ] videos
and chat no uh
i tend to just take all the photos
myself like
what i found through research is a lot
of instagram girls like to do like
almost like photo shoot style where
everything's
very produced and then there's a niche
for people who like to see you do like
day-to-day [ __ ] that looks more like
instagram that's what i growl
yeah as if like you sent the picture to
them yes yeah
that's the difference have you been
selling uh
undies in your socks still uh socks i
have i
sold one pair of underwear and then
afterwards i was like hmm not gonna do
this anymore did they pay a premium
though
they paid a pretty penny for it like a
hundo
mm-hmm yeah you got it did when were
they worn underwear
yeah it was like once i went to the gym
like two days ago
on your mom's house showed this video
this guy he's like whispering he's like
my wife's asleep
he's actually got these underwear
and he goes he goes this guy's so weird
he's like yeah she says she's 24. just
got done working out
because this is where her pooper would
be used oh that's raunchy
oh yeah yeah he goes i'm hard i'm hard
he's like trying to whisper because his
wife's sleeping i'm so hard right now
he's all like it's a staple in
commercial oh my gosh
why would you record yourself too i
don't know why you bring it up chin
it's it's your mom's house on their
youtube underwear yeah they're youtube
that's one of the best podcasts out
there
he's like oh i'm so hard right now yeah
put your leave your underwear in the
[ __ ] no not that one
go down that's right maybe all right
yeah that's there and then searching
there
um i know it's the beginning of their
episode go down
recent one um let me go to videos i
would probably yeah probably three weeks
ago
yeah they have two main videos yeah um
what's up just
four weeks three weeks um
see if it's the three weeks ago this one
587 yeah
he's like oh that's pungent that's
exactly what daddy said how about the
way the cigarette broke his arm
i didn't know he was a hooper i hear
everybody
you know yeah [ __ ] on america's
politics i'm like have you read
familiar germans apparently we haven't
heard about them no go
go you guys are clowns i think
[Music]
those three weeks ago go to the one that
says uh
go down this one no go down that's two
weeks ago
it's not two weeks ago go to that one
month ago see if that's it this one yeah
go to ymhstudios.com
natural being i'm gonna go
no what are you go back jen all i am oh
we'll find it um
two weeks ago i don't think it was two
weeks ago what what did we just get
which one did we just go to
wasn't this one uh go to the two months
ago see if that's it
see the one that says 581
hi mommies and chomos and my queen's
above 18.
this episode was recorded a few weeks
ago
uh before we had an incident where my
husband
nope because he's playing basketball
against uh suit earlier than this
so that was before he broke his one two
weeks ago then maybe
go two that's three go though they go
yeah i go that one
yeah 586.
i've got the antibodies buddy all right
let's start the show
excited i mean let's do it let's get
ready that looks like the
where the bunk hole was right because
they kind of look like
kind of look like [ __ ] stains oh yeah
there's the [ __ ] right there
so let's give it a whiff he gets his
nose ready
oh oh that is pungent
punches you can actually smell some [ __ ]
oh my goodness this is hot this is
giving me a boner right now
oh erection achieved actually [ __ ]
achieved dude
what's up dog how crazy weird those are
who are buying your underwear that's
who's money
you know i try not to think too much
about what they do with it i just sell
it and now
i have a very clear image oh keep doing
it
teach their own yeah keep doing it yeah
[ __ ] funny though
not really funny it's just kind of gross
would you sell your underwear
no again i'm not going to the post
office and ups the ship underwear it's
too much
i can't send my brother a pair of shoes
because i'm not going
taking time i'm too lazy for me that's
how i felt too i felt like i was
shipping off like a little secret
they would ask you to like oh what's it
have like clothes
oh there's some clothes what's the value
of this 50 bucks
you get an assistant cat who does it for
you just have my sister work for me
yeah hire your sister to make the
shipments
yeah yeah just have her do it keep it in
the thing though like
uh i don't know i had a weird feeling
after i sent it out i was like well
this is the only one i'm probably gonna
do you only did one yeah i only did one
if it's
popping like if there's a demand i would
i mean yeah i'd keep what are we doing
here
yeah [ __ ] it how many requests a day do
you get from like panties
uh panties i'll get maybe two or three a
day you get socks more though
on socks at the beginning i got and then
they kind of fizzled out now a lot of
people want dick ratings
dick right like how big is my money yeah
like they'll send a picture of their
dick
and water for that that's the thing i
don't open any photos or videos because
it they have the same feature as
instagram where it's blurred out so you
have to click on it in order to see
yeah and i tell people i don't open up
photos or videos unless you
i'm doing a dick rating and i try to
deter people from
showing me their dick or seeing it so
i'm like oh it's
i don't know like fifty dollars they're
like okay and some people are willing to
pay fifty dollars
yeah so like i'll do it for fifty
dollars but anything other than that so
what do you say
i tell them how i feel about their
dinner
so like i will tell them what i think
about size and like the actual photo
itself like if you're like
sending this to someone i'm like okay
maybe change the angle here like i don't
like this
position but if you do this maybe like
trim before you
send a photo are you getting big dicks
uh i've gotten i'd say like two or three
big dicks and
everything was pretty average yeah
mm-hmm makes sense
yeah yeah that's a cool because if you
got a big ding-a-ling you don't need a
dick right here that's the thing
you don't need a dick rating it's more
so you want me to see your dick that's
right yeah that's that's
not about like actually rating the deal
yeah because i want you to know what i'm
working
average is trying to know what's up like
hey like i just want to make sure
everything's
good yeah yeah what a crazy business
you've created
yeah yeah good for you good for you i'm
happy
i'm traumatizing i'm gonna make these
vlogs
it's a little bit more
get out of my face cat helps me though
because if i put her in a thumbnail
you get way more clicks chin likes to
use me as clickbait i do yeah
that's oh that's more like that's why i
decided to do only fans if anyone's
going to monetize off of me it's going
to be me
correct there you go there we go i made
500
you made what i made five dollars this
month for what i'm just kidding from
your vlog oh
they don't make much money if you don't
get your ass the only fan stop
bullshitting
i know gotcha show that dangling players
find a niche i gotta find she's just
different uh right because it's just
different
girl you know yeah it's a little
different 40 year old dude
but you got the editing skills and stuff
you know i feel like i'm gonna help you
let me be able to help you out
i know everyone's saying too i just
don't know what to do
tick-tock was looking for young
influencers
yeah bro if you don't post your r b
singing ass on tick tock bruh
get a lot of views i gotta seriously
think about it then you know bert
christopher reposted one of those
one of the songs i did too oh you did it
was very sweet what'd you do in those
jeans
no tracy chapman you posted on instagram
yeah oh yeah oh yeah really good
coverage um he
well his is gone he put on his story but
it's like one of those reels it's on
your your page though right yeah
yeah there you go brilliant
maybe we can make
look at that jersey why did it stop it
was always that real so it's like 30
seconds
yeah that was really good thank you guys
have you heard like the dance version of
that
no i don't think i wanna oh it's
fantastic it's good oh
dude for like raving and stuff dude it's
nice
it's a great song although all the way
around all the layers or anything
but you also like logic yeah i do like
logic top five
top five you'll have some [ __ ] so i
can find it and then we just can't play
it on
the podcast i'll find it
chin can you dance no bro we get you a
bt
we get you a individual bts or whatever
your solo
career bro i know dude it's kind of has
fast car featuring dakota i got it
jonah's oh that's it right there yeah
hit it
[Music]
tampa
[Music]
yeah this one's nice yeah there you go i
appreciate that one that's my gift to
you guys for the day that was that was a
solid gift brandon yeah nice
yeah what did you gift us
that's gross did i give y'all a gym i
gave you all motivation here's that
terrible story
this one your best friend killing a guy
just brought this
podcast he was like
oh i know don't worry about that
just talking about cars have you posted
any other
music chin you did a genuine one right
didn't you mine you didn't call him
you've never heard that dave matthews
that's just too hard i told you the
guitar he's guitar i give him so much
props
it's [ __ ] it's insane it's not like
regular playing hashtag free britney
did you see the documentary no i didn't
watch it we totally got one problem
yeah yeah you could have we could have
you said you know so funny you're so
funny
even though we told you like we already
covered it i was really hoping i thought
you would have watched it
how are you not gonna watch it i was
gonna watch it this weekend i'm doing a
little too late
oh too late it's over it's over you you
literally said hashtag free brittany
uh she came out and said something
recently i guess britain oh cause we
because we brought her up i think so
is it because of us i like to think so
but i doubt it but uh to think so
her uh her husband her boyfriend is like
mad as hell about her uh
pops that dime piece boyfriend yeah who
is that he's not even from
any spares what you say oh
can't believe his pronunciation is from
three years ago i was only left behind
on stage but i'm taking the time to
learn and be a normal person
i love okay that's not a statement
what was that um no her boyfriend that's
pretty much it
like go to a boyfriend she has this
dying piece boyfriend yeah
no matter what we think a person's life
is compared to that one
oh remember let's go to the top here
each person has their story that's what
she said
boom i'm rooting for her me too i'm
[ __ ]
i'm rooting for britney hashtag free
britney brittany if you're listening
we love you you know damn that's our
boyfriend right now
where is he from again heaven
makes sense from heaven
i don't know if we can actually see this
article oh it won't let us
see no we have to subscribe the other
subscribe to see you guys
why would we subscribe yeah too kevin
federline
released a statement he's backing her up
because he should also
use the diet kev k
fed's still fit dawg talking about that
thing have you seen me is he
mayor's boot camp oh there's no
involvement with graduate britney and
her attorney asking to remove jamie as a
conservative he stayed out with
conservative
issues um he thinks joey montgomery has
done a mineral job no position state
regarding the concern all right
he said kevin and brittany kids are
doing great kevin's enjoying watching
them grow up and evolve
uh kevin enjoys the full extent of
custody that he has both parties are
working well exchanging custody
all right well okay oh so like they're
they're on good terms apparently
that's good we're making we're making
[ __ ] progress there you go right here
there it is
oh dick yeah a little dime piece
what does he do practices feed him uh
probably model
right yeah yeah probably model well he's
dating britney so
damn do you think
how old is brittany she your age how are
we just 41.
older than me she has to be 40s early
really yeah
she's older 40s now she hit 39.99
right oh she just turned 39. oh she a
december baby
wow all right let's go some current
events all right
first one okay so there is a video that
went viral have you guys seen it yes man
the black community is in
okay so there is a woman who ran out of
her
hair product and she's trying to get
that like slick back pony look that a
lot of black girls would do edges
and she yeah she basically tried to lay
lay her edges make sure
everything's in order but she ran out of
her product so she had the idea to use
gorilla
glue instead of hairspray and she
has a video this one that went viral let
me see oh my god
hey y'all
my hair has been like this for about a
month now it's not my choice
no it's not a choice
when i do my hair like you know finish
it off with a little got the big glue
spray
you know just to keep it in place well i
didn't have any more got to be glue
space so i used this
gorilla glue spray
bad bad idea
yo look my hair it don't move
you hear what i'm telling you it don't
move
i've washed my hair 15
times and it don't move
stiff wear
my hair so i'm going to tell you i like
this [ __ ] looks fly though
ever run out of got to be blue spring
that's what you're looking for gorilla
glue did the job her room's going to
happen
yeah yeah so she went to the hospital
right yeah she had a friend trying to
help her with
uh some they got like uh well she's like
they're called they called gorilla glue
yeah gorilla glue is like
definitely not made for hair we can do
is use rubbing alcohol that should help
she did that
yeah she bought a couple of things to
try to take off the gorilla glue
it worked a little bit but not enough to
take it off completely she had a friend
help her cut part of her hair off
and when she went to the hospital they
said that her scalp is actually going to
have chemical burns from that
yeah she's from louisiana i was born at
the hospital
listen here's the thing she is this
what's this uh is this a video
of her watching i don't know enter in
the hospital
that poor girl man but also gorilla i
know
she's shh
chemical burns man yeah you guys
probably never dyed your hair right i
have i have sisters
quite a few times blonde blondie i had
red polka dots
[ __ ] yeah yeah i know i was different
yeah i i've
dyed mine like a like a mint blue and
that that
but they have to like completely since
my hair is so dark did you completely
bleach it first and then you add color
yeah
do that bleach get so spicy yeah
especially when it gets closer to
charlie's
washington when you put all that malcolm
x yeah yeah oh yeah you put that poison
in your hair
yeah it burns that's how they would get
that palm going bro
so she was like she's all right
hopefully hopefully she's had
several doctors reach out to her saying
that if
she needs their help they'll go to her
and try to help to the best of their
abilities but
uh yeah she's just in the process of
trying to edges are gone
i'm trying to figure out where she's
gonna what she's gonna do i think she's
gonna have to start fresh
after she gets it up gets it out because
she can't even shave it she can't do
anything yeah that's the thing
like you gotta get it out and then just
shave did they get it out no
uh as of now no they're still trying
that poor girl i know right so bad
possible gorilla glue also gorilla glue
oh god
that's some peanut butter falcon [ __ ]
just don't go to the party
just don't go to the party it's never
that serious yo she couldn't get her
edges laid in time so she was like let
me get the glue on
that's what she said all right you know
i have sisters brendan okay so kim
kardashian posted
a photo of a painting on her ig story
and she said that
uh her daughter north was
uh i was she like nine ten is she
no no i don't think she's she's seven
right northwest is your name right yeah
yeah northwest i know because people
think it's fake right
yeah so she's seven and uh kim said that
she was taking a bunch of painting
lessons
and that she was proud of the work that
north did so she posted a photo of it
onto her instagram story
and a bunch of people were making fun of
her saying north absolutely didn't paint
this why are you
trying to do all this for the gram and
she went off on a bunch of people but
people are also kind of right
i don't think you don't think sh
seven-year-old paint that paint that
she got five-year-old man you've been
painting for a minute or drawn from
this and then she also followed this
with a post
of art that kanye did when he was a kid
that showed his
like artistic he was big and high when
he was young right yeah some people get
it
maybe you think they ain't spending the
money for her to get the best
uh painting trainer to help her out
she's seven
artists artist there you go thanks dog
maybe this is
the artwork that she said kanye did when
he was a kid
i don't know how old he was and what
like kid kind of was 27 years old
he did that last week here's some of
kanye's stuff when he's 37
to back off you know i'm telling you man
you know i'm around five olds and i see
all their their their paintings and
drawings and stuff
maybe they should two years older maybe
they got savon on their hands but
it ain't even close
i think it could happen it could happen
let me see youtube's seven-year-old
painting this kid's 11 11 he's 11.
but that's pretty good damn eleven to
seven is a
huge huge difference it is a huge
difference five to sevens and say
different maybe
you know i like to think that she's not
[ __ ] but also the kardashians so
everything's smoke and mares right from
their looks
everything they're doing so it's like
it's hard to believe
anything that's more like it i think
right you know what right here like that
kind of painting art yeah like it was
like
a shirt like my son will bring home and
i'm like what the [ __ ] dude
alligators don't have wings
like you know it's not going to make the
fridge homeboy you know it's like i
can't put no alligator with wings on my
[ __ ] fridge
it's a dragon dog yeah you know god damn
well
[ __ ] gorillas don't have scales
the [ __ ] they bring homie like dude why
did your teacher tell you
yeah he'll bring just some wild
and one eye's like bigger than the other
like it's gonna scare your little
brother bro
so you mean no uh i'd be
it's like it's the kardashians i'm gonna
believe it you don't believe it yeah i
like to believe it
i mean her dad is kanye west who when he
you know kind of savant when it comes to
music
that's that's bob ross that is tough to
do man yeah
that is [ __ ] tough to do as seven did
the teacher probably help a lot
yeah yeah maybe she did the grass yeah
maybe
she did the grass but the water
collection yeah look at the reflection
on
the water that's that's so detailed
maybe she maybe savant hopes she is but
the
the problem is again the connection she
even signed it yeah sure
but one eye is bigger than the other in
her all right even this like just a
reflection here and then it's blue
that tree bro yeah go to their mouth
everything no that's that's amazing work
and god pop more power to her if she's
really painting those i don't believe it
but what do i know i'm just around kids
all the time and there's some little
there's some talented kids at tiger
school and they ain't doing that
[ __ ] same stuff right
damn i guess i'm the only one that
believes you don't believe in alec
that's fun to believe but also it's the
kardashians like her face and ass are
fake i'm supposed to expect this
painting's real
you know what i'm saying they're going
through a divorce and [ __ ] acting like
everything's their fair points
come on they ain't nothing real about
the kardashians and i'm a fan
i'm a fan okay i think it's real so
speaking of free brittany there was an
old
uh video footage from craig ferguson
where he refused to mock uh britney
spears on his show way back in the day
and it's going viral now
now i remember what's happened it's been
happening in the press in the media
recently and particularly in the
so-called news outlets
looking at the world i i kind of had a
turn
when i used to watch america's funniest
home videos you know you'd be laughing
at the kid falling over and then you go
wait a minute put down the damn camera
and help your
kid what the hell is wrong with you and
i
and i and i think we're kind of holding
the cam and people are falling off
powers right people are
people are dying that anna nicole smith
woman she
died it's not a joke
you know it's it stops being funny that
she's got a six week old kid or six
month old kid what the hell is that
you know and i i and i i'm starting to
feel uncomfortable about making fun of
these people and for me combination of a
certain amount of joy in it
it should be about about us attacking
the powerful people attacking the
politicians and the
and the trumps and the and the blue
hearts of the world
going after them we should be attacking
the vulnerable people
and i think i i'm gonna this is totally
a miracle this is just for me
i think my aim's been off a bit recently
i i want to change a bit so tonight
no britney spears jokes this woman has
two kids
she's 25 years old she's a baby herself
she's a baby that's great damn
that was possible man yeah shout out to
craig for that one
yeah yeah yeah only the other media
members were like that
yeah it's just like i mean like
when you make jokes on her it's just
kind of low-hanging fruit yeah it's
weird
it's kind of just kind of weak
especially during that time it was just
like bro everyone's just
[ __ ] with her i mean what you said a
million dollars
for a picture for the million dollars
for a picture why
britney spears she get no money she
don't get none of that money
yeah you're going to take a picture of
me and make a million off of it i don't
see none of it
and that's why you start and only fancy
exactly
all right i'm doing [ __ ] i'll get
black panther too
[Laughter]
that should be sick it's gonna
there was a lawyer who was on a zoom
call with a judge and another lawyer
uh and they were supposed to discuss the
case but for some reason one of the
lawyers he couldn't get this cat filter
off of his zoo
but i'm here live i'm not a cat
let me see this chip
[Laughter]
turned on
[Laughter]
don't know how to remove it
it's me fellas it's not your chat no
[ __ ] for the sound of this
arrow next to this i love how the eyes
go
they're trying to coach them up all
right so just go to settings
these kids were probably [ __ ] with us
i love like you try to explain the cat
eyes just get sad
i'm live
speaking of kids vernon you are a fan
said this in right
uh jay sent this to me jason that's okay
um it's kids
scarface is a kid's school place yeah
i've seen this i've been saying you've
never seen it now is it funny
i think it was real i thought that was
like a joke no it's an old video
this is dope say hello hold on
[Music]
[Music]
michelle pfeiffer yeah you do coke and
you kill people
that's wonderful honey
i got a [ __ ] drink for one
you son of a bee oh
[Laughter]
that's what i'm saying that's not
anything
i'm trying to tell you man
there's an audience for this what that
looks like
she had a costume
cameras parents helped out with this
[ __ ] too
okay so sir you are fudging me your
friend you're the best
well please say hello to my little
friend
where the oh my god
what school approved this i don't know
that's cool the world is yours
what the [ __ ] who is
[Music]
unreal oh that's so funny
super bad parenting super bad but also
awesome
this is funny how i said the world is
yours and
[Laughter]
that's unbelievable i got so hard for me
to believe it's real
unreal wonderful yeah all right so this
thing is going viral
it's kind of frustrating when i watch it
but i'll just play it for you so people
are on her side by the way
the which on whose side this girl who
just came back from hot yoga
and she's talking about what fitness
instructors what they say how it's not
cool
so i'll play it free right now let's
ignore the fact that my teeth are purple
[Music]
the most annoying thing i think about
going to
a workout class i went to a socially
distanced
hot yoga class love hot yoga but i hate
when the instructors
go off and say we're gonna you know work
off all those cheat meals
i and they just keep talking about the
food you may have eaten and how
exercise is just to combat the food that
you eat
food is fuel it's not something you need
to
fear you need to work off like they go
hand in hand
they're not like fighting each other
like they work together
you need to eat anyways that's it that's
my rant
um
[Music]
happy from day yeah so here's the thing
that's just like and she's getting all
the support too it's like
that's what's wrong with that let's go
girl take ownership of your fat body
it's like no
hold on her cholesterol is through the
roof now you [ __ ]
i'm glad she has a super positive
attitude about life
you're out of shape girl and so you go
to that class and they're trying to tell
you hey
you're trying to burn off these cars
because you ate like [ __ ] yeah
those are facts but that's it's easy to
go yeah i'm fat and i eat this and
you know i'm sick of them telling me i
need to stop being like this because
that's the that's the easy wrap
it's not cool to drink it does not make
your body feel good
no i don't feel good depending on what
you eat depending on what you eat
it's also depending on what you eat
right so if you good stuff but not that
much
here's the thing start your own class
girls you seem like you'd be a great
instructor especially with that mindset
no you wouldn't i'm sick of it what
world are we no you're not
yeah no you didn't though no you
wouldn't do that because listen
more power to you you're severely out of
shape you don't know how to work out
you don't know how to eat right you
don't have any discipline it's yeah it's
like
it's just saying that it's just saying
like they're like they're mean for
saying like we're working on food no
that's what we're doing i'm just telling
you like hey
it's not me then everyone who rallies
around her is also on discipline and
out of shape yeah but it's so much
easier to go yeah don't let them shame
me for eating like that girl no no [ __ ]
no no problem you can eat like that but
you eating like that every day
every day and that's that's not cool
are those all those uh there's a lot of
sugar full of sugar delicious
full of sugar i mean yeah of course
they're delicious
but there's a lot of sugar in there well
it's a brazilian uh
cuisine any i mean appetite just because
it's brazilian well american we could
put more sugar in it but
got it guys but again it's they say it's
healthy for you in brazil
but over here is too much sugar sugar
it's a lot of calories yeah
yep a ton of sugar no matter what like
my boy henry grace eats it every day
but he doesn't need any carbs he didn't
eat bread now also like yeah he's
watching them
yeah so i mean they kind of have to tell
you
you know they have to guide you on what
to [ __ ] eat and what not to [ __ ]
eat right
let's just assume that this instructor
is skinny
okay so earlier y'all was talking about
skinny people
telling people
maybe that instructor is thick and got
in shape i bet you that instructor has
discipline though huh
i bet you that instructor i mean yeah we
didn't sound like don't know we didn't
really sound like that girl
no no no i hate weird
no we didn't no we didn't because if
that instructor was
thick and lost weight i'm gonna listen
to that person oh yeah we don't know
what the instructions
i have no clue that's what i'm saying i
see what you're just saying not the
instructions
some skinny like rail [ __ ] who's like
don't eat that assay you work it off
girl that's like
what the [ __ ] you're talking about yeah
yeah work it out what have you worked on
yeah
i appreciate you calling society's weird
though where they rally around that
because that every because it's so much
harder to lose weight and be disciplined
but what are they saying like one of the
big things of like kovid
is like if you're if you're overweight
out of shape and if it gets you she's
gonna get you
like if she got ko but she's fine you
know what i'm saying so like so like are
we shaming or is it
yeah it's just weird that like no i get
what he's saying so
start your own class no relax no yeah
yeah yeah i don't know but yeah again
hello
supposed to make you sweat you know he
supposed to be skinny
i just think there's nothing wrong with
saying burning off food that's all i
don't think yeah
yeah what she's what she's upset about i
don't think
anything i think the instructor's like
hey you probably have that cheat meal
today that's going to help you burn this
off you know
yeah promoting health yeah and what you
say like
food is fuel but like also what the [ __ ]
food is fuel
yeah no we get that for survival we've
gone way past that girl
i'm eating your ass first if this plane
[Laughter]
crashed
um justin bieber i got he got this
custom rolls royce from
that one place you know west coast
customs hit my right place
and i don't know what i think about it
it looks cool in a picture but then
here's a yeah let's go with customers
just go to
too much yeah i mean the front looks
cool back or some [ __ ]
i also pick my ride people yeah yeah oh
[ __ ]
back looks cool like you we know you
like roller skates so we put a roller
rink in the back
where they put everything in people's
cars i think it'd be dope if they didn't
do those
fenders on the wall yeah unless it was
floating or something but there's gonna
be wheels under it it looks kind of
cheesy i think
you got it yeah yeah but that's it
justin bieber just got that
yeah he sent it there for them to hook
it up
yeah [ __ ] yeah these guys they just with
their imagination you got to tell them
what to do
if you drop it off like go crazy they
just go overboard yeah
i mean at least it's cleaner but i just
don't like the concept because hiding
the wheels the wheels yeah because
you know the wheels are under there you
can take those out yeah like a wide body
would be sick
yeah um so these paranaques designed for
barack obama going for 25k
44th president on them those are sick i
would not
i would rock the [ __ ] you rocked the
[ __ ] out oh i don't think i can
uh is there only one pair yeah
yeah that's why there's only one pair
that's why i'm 25 grand
yeah those are [ __ ] sick man
i can't tell those are saucy would you
rock those man
i'll play all these those are sick hyper
dumps are dope
yeah yeah um
obviously we've been tagged a ton in
this one i'm sure you've seen this
already yeah i haven't seen it you
haven't
chapelle chappelle this is going to be
your life story as far as being on the
show they're going to tag you in all the
cheerleading stuff let me see but this
guy's insanely good
yeah damn holy [ __ ] look at him go
look at that holy [ __ ]
dude are you crazy dizzy when you do a
bunch of flips
you gotta go right yeah uh
not too dude that's pretty impressive
because you're like right
yeah because you're like watching you
you you have to spot something
so the spot so you spotting something
doesn't make you dizzy okay
it's like weird like when you're just
like
watching is like what is there a certain
amount you can do before you start to
get
like i doubt he's i doubt he's like
super dizzy
like right there would be like what the
hell kind of falls back right
yeah no someone is awake oh no that's
not i just don't think he knew
where exactly where he was he was that
on on that one but no the dude's
impressive from the go to his
profile he's a dope dude you know him i
don't know him personally but
i just know of him just like he does a
lot of tricking which tricking is like
is that like parkour yeah in a sense
we're like
stuff like this yeah yeah but he's ooh
i need her in her head bro he kicked
that girl in the head
let me see don't go to that one boom
[ __ ]
i need her jesus christ first of all she
should have been spontaneous
which one he's pretty uh trying to the
other one where he's on the mat right
there
where his hands are up this one no the
uh no the
parallel this one yep
he's a big boy too can you do that on a
[ __ ] chapelle yeah
you need to come with us when me and
tiger go this place they have that uh
the trampoline parks those are those are
pretty fun no this place guys
it's like a park parkour oh the parkour
one it's called tempest
oh hell yeah tiger loves it dude chad
chatsworth where's that all right it's
kind of by me it's without bending my
knees to jump
it's me but north yeah there's some
really good uh he's
short i'll tell you uh i have a homie
that's really [ __ ] badass
type in i am santan in instagram yeah
swanton
santwan i am s-a-n-t
oh what's steven you're doing on the
guitar there playing some dope ass [ __ ]
rage against machina
yes steven uh a-s-a-n
i'm a correct so i cheered with this
dude he's really
he was yeah uh go like
go oh he was in that video twerking
go oh he's clearly a straight man no
please
go oh damn buddy like look at
yeah oh dude he's he's insanely go him
and his man are shredding mm-hmm
you know when you in your man shredded
go to uh sorry to the
one to the left where's like three dudes
you got an apple you got a booty on him
he's on the left like he's just
it doesn't move bro like he's boom
there's another one little flip sash
hold on there's keep going yes
brother you take off all this
cheerleading stuff keep going or you
just oh
he's got oh man i'm proud about that
man making out honey
[Laughter]
hell yeah if you don't scroll all the
way down how far
faster can you see a lot of while yeah
i think he did like probably like three
three three seasons you want the
cheerleaders
no he they had him in a while style he
did a little bit in the wild yeah he did
a little bit of wild style he lost
yeah we cheered together at uh
louisville
that's right i'm gonna go faster okay
yeah oh go go go go go okay okay
watch that one in the middle who made it
watch him see him coming watch him watch
him hit this right here
boom
protect them nuts yeah he's really good
wow yeah that's the homie do you have to
wear a cup if you do stuff like that i
don't know i
should i ain't never done that
i never yeah i've never gotten that to
you know
the splits flipping in the air landing
on my dangle lane like that i can't do
that i'm nuts
yeah he said hey
[Laughter]
can you could you do the splits no but
you would stretch a lot for
yeah flexible what'd you say i was never
like crazy flex really my hamstrings are
tight
oh yeah you probably could yeah not for
me you don't want to learn splits
nah i don't care no no come on dog
there's a lot of fish to fry you see
rogan do the middle splits yep don't
give a [ __ ]
what else you got jen um just an update
on rebel wilson
you guys know rebel wilson oh yeah oh
yeah yeah looks good right pitch perfect
now it's kidding this is the one that's
her now she's on that adele plan
and she that's her again she's like oh
wow she looks great yeah
she's filming something right now right
i'm sure she's like all the time i've
always been yeah
she's australian yes yes she's a beast
she is dude killing me she's so funny
yeah
so funny so funny
yeah she looks good she does she looks
good yeah yeah she's good for her
that's that adele are people uh skinny
shame here no
not at all they better not be bro i
can't wait for us to take pictures like
this
me too dude just outside of a trailer
like like
skinny we'll be like your friend in this
game boot boy
oh yeah yeah y'all trying to dance
like what you saying so you know what
your mom was supposed to come off the
bottle they made a new label and name
and now it's called the pearl
milling company and people don't like it
poison anyways
people don't like it because it sounds
like a like a factory instead of
something good
yeah and because aunt jemima was racist
it was based i had to look it up but
it's basically the mammy trope yeah that
the minstrel characters racial
stereotype
it's a cool picture though i mean i wish
i wish it wasn't based on it
company yeah i don't use that [ __ ]
anyways i love that
organic the amber [ __ ] uh you get it
from whole foods the real syrup like
sucked out of a tree oh it's like
organic real it's nice oh it's better
oh yeah yeah that [ __ ] that's just sweet
that's that aunt jemima that's that's
right i mean that's where i'm at yeah is
that it jen that's it
right on brother all right kids tampa
florida february 26 or 27th
and then between then uh it'll be added
to f a t
k z dot com i'm gonna slap j shop's fat
ass round for not adding it already let
me write it away refreshing
refresh let me see if i get a slap i'm
around
for what oh i don't have to slap him
oh go up march so tampa
favorite 26 27th that's a friday
saturday two shows friday two shows
saturday
tampa florida get your tan asses get
your super bowl sale brand asses out
there tampa florida temp
improv but then just added cleveland
ohio one of my favorite places on planet
earth
we'll have to go to i think it's called
s
uh slants slithers
i think sandwiches okay great breakfast
let's do that um cleveland ohio at
hilarities shout out to i love hillary
the manager there
march 11th through the 13th cleveland
ohio you're on the clock
but baby you get all the lebron juice
you want there yeah
oh yeah it's a steel mill love cleveland
dude
have you been there should we go to
akron or is that far from
i think it's florida [ __ ] yeah oh god
you know that's the
rock and roll i could live live in
cleveland cleveland's dope oh it is yeah
i'm gonna rock cleveland jersey out
there
cleveland ohio hilarious is right by the
house of blues yeah march 11th march
13th
cleveland ohio let's do this baby and
then back in miami miami florida
march 25th through the 27th then naples
florida april 15th
april 17th but cleveland tampa you're on
the clock then cleveland come get some
f-a-t-k-z dot-com anything
sick boy related go to thickboy.com the
helmet signature giveaway i'll have news
for that on my social media
uh the limited edition specialized
collab is on there as well
once those are gone they're gone if any
sizes are out they're gonna be out
um is the limited edition thing with
specialized long sleeve short sleeves
thick boy
smiley hoodies thick boy smiley hats
sweats short sleeves tight eyes go to
thickboy.com
chapelle hey kansas city i think i'm
going to try uh q39 but
i'll be okay 39's again yeah i'm gonna
do that one february 25th
joe's joe's okay i'll do joe's so
february 25th through the 27th
i'll be at the comedy club of kansas
city tickets chapelle lacy.com
uh i'm going to that joe's barbie is it
just called joe's barbecue yep
gas station right in the gas station and
then march 5th and 6th i'll be in austin
texas
those are only two shows so one each
night get those [ __ ] tickets right
now let's [ __ ]
party in austin texas brother gets at f
a t k z for chappelle
or chapelle let's do the damn thing
all right we out all right hashtag free
brittany
272.
what's up man they call me chappelle
lacy uh you know with my vans on they
look like sneakers
uh these i just got these um the vans
they're collab with uh
[ __ ] on them
yeah but they got the crossbones on you
know about to not skating these hoes but
i like to wear them you know what i'm
saying i got some real skate shoes on
doug
if you ain't got a passport you ain't
[ __ ]
these for my boys at suplex philly sent
me these
the passport nikes
let's go let's go let's see
suplex philly i need the uh the britain
passport ones
there's only two pairs
272. that's how you do it
yeah lose weight hashtag lose weight
hashtag losers like free britney
that's the freebie 72. yeah i mean i'm a
grower not a shower but i'm gonna show
you you need to grow into those
[ __ ]
you got two feet
what size
you might get your daddy's shoes on man
you know i got flat feet it's almost all
my shoes
all my shoes i'm 11. i'm 11. you always
can't cut the
i know